come be a part of the new face of Freddy
fazbear's pizza what what could go wrong
even less money dude
what do you sound like that guy that
probably died in the last one no where's
chica I soon found she couldn't even see
chica coming huh that's not a joke for
the internet to enjoy oh no no you don't
go into that vent don't
[ __ ] come on okay okay well then she
gives if she wants to serve me a cupcake
I think it was written pizzaiolo
was bad screw you I'm to stay here go
away also why is the guy on the phone
still alive it's not right hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to five nights at Freddy's
welcome actually to five nights at
Freddy's to get some scented candles
take a nice herbal bath smoke some weed
I don't care do something relax that I
attended an event that I had to dance at
eppley so